[Music]
hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are gonna watch the
Dark Crystal Age of resistance trailer
for Netflix this one came out like a
month ago we came across the comic-con
behind-the-scenes sneak peek that looks
really cool but more importantly the
reason we're doing this because this is
top reward tier requests up patreon from
a man named Eric hosts man he's gonna
get his own puppet character horse man
I'm super excited for it Eric is that
guy who got that real rejects
tattoo we will meet in person one day
specifically because you did that that's
how easy it's gonna be to get us to fly
out to see it guys anywho let's watch
this trailer
[Music]
[Music]
Alex so the dark ago who wants
everything in countries what is a
darkening
[Music]
I regret not washing this trailer we all
make mistakes we all make
verse 2
[Music]
first many ending slavery for us some
mood
[Music]
this looks so beautiful
[Music]
ten no one
[Music]
I'm only costs five million dollars Wow
five million dollars it looks like a
great sequel to happy time murders okay
so I never actually saw Dark Crystal
that's why I was hesitant to check this
trailer out Dark Crystal has been like
present throughout my life but it is one
I didn't catch it's like I saw a
labyrinth in the neverending story and a
whole bunch of other things but I've
only been aware of the Dark Crystal over
time it's interesting to me that they
are doing a show inspired by because I
know the following is a rather cult
based following that has grown over time
because it was like a moderate success
when it first came out in the theatres
it wasn't a flop but it wasn't eight
wasn't it or anything
yeah and I know but he's definitely
gained its status over time yeah guys at
the time it was like this super dark and
I'll say like I've seen clips of the
Dark Crystal
over my whole life as well get the basic
gist it's always had this kind of icky
off-putting aesthetic to me or does look
kind of disturbing and dark especially
the Skeksis yeah looking at it here
because of its modern day that's more
sleek looking it doesn't have that
there's not anything in the way of the
magic of it of this sort of like oh when
this world is in harmony it's really
beautiful and yeah watch it going like
wow look how beautiful this little yeah
words any time I've seen footage of the
darker so the movie I always have that
feeling and it develops in my heart of
just oh this looks like a twisted
version of what should be a beautiful
kids movie and that's the way two people
responded to the marketing of it back
then yeah and over time it has above
those following Jim Henson train has
been going on for a very long time
but I feel like lately in the past
couple of years I've been hearing Jim
Henson brought up more than ever it's
strange to me that they're doing this
not because it doesn't look good this
looks like there should be a ground
breaking TV show to experience I'm so I
don't know where Netflix you're always
hearing stories about Netflix about to
go bankrupt and [ __ ] look at it crazy
this looks and today have the audience
built-in to watch this it hasn't had
this like long lasting franchise you
know one movie yeah forever again I'm
talking about following it up forever as
well even recently the spirit brothers
who were two guys I very much enjoyed
they were talking about making a sequel
movie or some things like this thing
that's always been percolating and they
didn't do it because Louis letterer
director of the transporter 2 loved it I
think if that's the one he directed is
the right pick for this job you've seen
jelly and Bob Hoskins go toe-to-toe
unleashed you would know he's the right
one for this originally that movie was
supposed to be all puppets the most
highly praised MCU film The Incredible
Hulk Oh totally yeah you would know he's
the right person oh yes job I mean he's
done something that makes him the right
first actual credit I'm forgetting
probably I gotta fly check it out make
sure I won't be a total dick here's
something that makes them definitely
worked with a lot of CDs so that's good
because you're having more advanced
marriage of visual effects to these set
oh he did the first two transporter
movies look it's you that's right Luke
based song did not direct any of those
he just gets credit oh we did Clash of
the Titans that that Remender sri male
loved it now you see me there's a reason
everyone saw that are you brother
Grimsby that's it Sacha Baron Cohen
movie right yeah
that was great that was a beloved film
well somehow he's the right person I
don't know why he is but it looks like
he's pulling it off I can't just go off
of his passport because you might have a
good point the fact that they are
infusing CGI and a lot more heavily with
this show than they did with the movie
but what's cool is like the puppets look
great because a lot of money everybody
just CGI with the creatures but the fact
that they kept it animatronics puppets
and even a lot of the puppets I would
imagine probably have radio-controlled
maybe facial expressions or something
like that because these look a lot more
complicated than Muppets do you know oh
yeah absolutely that's a big thing I'm
wondering about for this show because of
the way Netflix produces the best of my
hopes for this kind of say this is what
could save them from being completely
demolished when Disney Plus and
everything else steals half their
content back the big thing I'm wondering
now is how all of these artistic mediums
are gonna collide in the now and what
kind of uncanny valley they will have to
dodge with that because it looked like
some of the creatures and some of the
moments might be CG enhanced yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I'm wondering if there's
gonna be a balance of all CG creatures
for certain scenes or set pieces and
then certain focal characters and
creatures as puppets like Dark Crystal
the first movie seems to be a pretty
specific kind of crowd that really
enjoys that film I think the mistake
that they can make with doing this is
only tending to the people who loved the
original movie you know what I mean like
you have to hook in people who are not
even gonna make the time to watch the
original movie yeah because a lot of
people won't what if they end up
watching the original movie and going I
hate this
I'm gonna watch your show yeah yeah and
I think this trailer did a really good
job at selling me out as a person who
hasn't even seen the first Dark Crystal
movie just like clips and whatever this
did a really good job making me go this
feels like an event
tell Netflix doesn't have a lot of shows
I feel like events they on a lot of
shows they have a lot of shows and then
they have strange things this show could
be an event hopefully yeah I think like
what the kind of fan base of this show
sumit Lee garner just off of the effects
alone it could be something pretty
special yeah I think there's something
that could appeal beyond the original
movie in the sense that this is so
fantasy and it's so unique looking even
now that you know I feel like it is
gonna fill a void no matter what that is
kind of missing they have to do their
own thing as well so instead of just
paying tribute but hey I'm sure it'll be
cool are you guys excited for this seems
like people are the Netflix account it
has five million and a half views people
have been requesting in our comments for
a lot seemed like a hell of a lot like
let's say five million people tuned in
if five million people watch a show is
that enough to keep this you know maybe
that seems like a pretty small number
for what the show is being produced
here's how we'll know if it does well
enough Netflix will actually break that
silence and tell us the numbers like
they did with stranger things otherwise
now if it gets a season two you'll have
your answer okay yeah because at this
point I'm like that's a lot of people
yeah five million people's a lot but is
that is that enough for this nine to
twenty dollar subscriptions just keep
this thing afloat it means strangers
think season three has their built-in
fan base and whatever and that was like
a super expensive season they put
together their trailers averaged from
like 15 to 40 million views so I don't
have any like expensive a sack I know
Simon Pegg is voicing in here but at the
same time I feel like this probably cost
probably as much as this didn't put
together probably cost a lot I do really
appreciate Netflix for investing in
these kinds of things is going to be
interesting to see whether or not this
has a broad if this can bring in that
broad appeal yeah alright guys well are
you excited for Dark Crystal age of
resistance comment below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell seeing and
notify whenever we got a new video up
you got to do both I know it's a lot of
work also I would like to say thank you
to Eric horseman here ich by sharing a
a little message thread that we had
going on earlier next is gay for guys
right Sigma I basically asked him he
brought up a list of ladies he would be
into here's who he said Evan Rachel Wood
Katheryn Winnick I don't know who that
is Scarlett Johansson
Tandi Newton carla Gugino Rose Byrne
Lucy Lawless gal gadot Christina
Applegate drew Barrymore and Lucy Liu
you did not mention Cameron she half a
second there because Christina Applegate
is blond I imagined a full set of
Charlie's Angels and then when you're
missing one but apparently he hates
Cameron Diaz yeah that's all I got from
this thread because he did not name
dropper yeah what gives hey even he even
clarifies this oh but he brought up he
said the sperm hair yeah oh is that like
an actual look that she has always
thought it was just she came up with
that bit and she was like like oh you
can we get some sperm on so she's like
that's not funny oh it's just what I do
you know wacky lady Cameron later iconic
Leigh